hi doctor thanks for taking my call
yes ma'am how can we help you okay so
about two years ago every time so for
about two years every time I'd sleep on
my right side
a hundred starts shaking and just on my
right side my shoulder and everything
and it starts shaking and it was
terrible and then I couldn't ride during
the day and then Thanksgiving time this
last year just two months ago I slipped
and broke my left wrist
ouch and I came in yeah and had an
surgery and you had a titanium thing but
in I came out of surgery and now my
right leg is stiff I can't walk I
shuffle I it freezes up and I don't know
what the heck's going on
am i right I'm saying how old are you
how are you Mary I'm just a little over
61 okay and how much you weigh 155 okay
how tall are you 5 6 ok that's about
right okay any other issues did you have
any like respiratory problems when
you're a kid or a teenager you know like
asthma bronchitis anything like that I
was on I had an ear infection solid for
ten years I'd get off of it and it's
been back and then if I get off of it
certainly back on so I took antibiotics
solid for ten years and I had about ten
years ago I had vitiligo and so now I've
been like other came up on me okay well
that's a deficiency of a single nutrient
cause usually by malabsorption and then
did you have any skin problems or yep
today do you have any skin problems any
eczema dermatitis or psoriasis rosacea
anything like that just a bit like okay
do you have children joven no Mary do
any of your kids I have asthma or
bronchitis or skin problems or bowel
problems no but no neither one of them
do okay so they're both perfectly
healthy not nothing if I were to examine
them or talk to them they would say
we've never been sick a day of my life
never had problems we're healthy
no they both the one I think is an
alcoholic and the other one doing so on
alcohol but she's known that colic so
they do have something going on okay
yeah okay no Charmaine yes
okay so what's what is you know based on
her children's stories her stories
what is Mary's basic underlying problem
here well she's got a gluten intolerance
yeah you get an A+ very good and at 100
and what is this 150 pounds 155 yeah
hundred fifty-five pounds so what would
you do for her as a supplement program
to support maze repair and maximize her
health benefits so she's not getting
fractured you know ankles and fingers
and having all this stuff going on well
for her issues I would suggest that she
takes probably two healthy bone and
joint packs mm-hmm and then vitamin d3
and and get on a gluten-free diet
obviously no way early rye oats
yeah give it all the inflammatory foods
no gluten no wheat bran or our oats that
means dog can't bird fish spouse partner
renter roommates mother-in-law kids
everybody that you come in contact with
it's got to be gluten free so no
cross-contamination in the laundry the
food prep surfaces the couches the beds
and so on cars etc then the Shar says
that your body weight she picked a good
one to two healthy bone and joint packs
for months a full dose for thing twice a
day get two bottles of the vitamin d3 we
have the spray you can have three
spritzes at breakfast and dinner it
tastes like lemonade and citrus vitamin
d3 or if you like two capsules I have to
take the capsules cuz they fly all the
time and so I have to have lightweight
and things that won't spill on my
clothes and so I take three of those
capsules twice a day the vitamin d3 and
then let's see also you're going to have
gluco gel in there with those two
healthy bone and joint packs I'd take 15
a day five at breakfast five at lunch
five at dinnertime and let's see here
what would you do to help her with these
chronic ear things I suspect she's got
osteoporosis of the skull so what would
you do to help her reduce that
inflammation so the doctors won't keep
giving your I can't believe for eight
ten
11 years he's getting antibiotics for an
ear infection there's and shermaine what
would you do SH we didn't deal with her
vitiligo which is a loss of skin color
kind of like Michael Jackson had very
common very very common disease were you
know they can't absorb the the nutrients
necessary for the skin to make skin
pigment and hair color eye color and
everything and then Michael Jackson
really had a severe either he was
actually criticized for bleaching
himself to look white because he
couldn't absorb any of those nutrients
necessary for skin color that's why were
gloves and the military uniforms and
high collars and everything lipstick
because he lost all the skin color eye
color everything hair color okay so what
would you do what would you add to the
two healthy bone and joint packs and the
other things we talked about what you
add to that to give her what's necessary
to support return of skin color well the
gluten-free diet is gonna help oh yeah
jorb the nutrients and I would add one
more specific product for that hair skin
and nails
well hair skin and nails would be good
you actually could take three of those
twice a day two bottles a month but
there's cofactors actually it's kind of
a weird thing because it's not the
actual product itself the thing that is
named after but it's the cofactors let's
say something like selenium it's the
cofactors in the selenium okay missing
you know when you when you have vitiligo
and white hair regardless of age and so
for babies are born with white hair
because mom is missing those those
nutrients so let's ever get two bottles
of our selenium not anybody slim because
nobody else has the cofactors and
they're they're necessary to support
healthy skin eye and hair color